*Quand je dis Craigs ,tu dis liste*
Craigs ?
Les amis il est temps de refaire un saut sur les petites perles de Craigslist
Parce que j'avais beaucoup aimé ça la dernière fois.
Les Américains sont farfelus
sont un peu foufou, ce sont des vrai ouistiti, des zigotos
Sur quoi nous allons tomber aujourd'hui, la question est totale
ON Y VA
Vintage Chuck E Cheese Showbiz Pizza
La dernière fois qu'j'ai vu des Animatroniques c'était dans Five Nights At Freddy's
Et ça m'a pas trop plu
* cri virile *
Olalaaaaa mais c'est glauque as fuck
J'sais pas si c'est glauque en soit ou si c'est à cause de Five Nights At Freddy's que-
Hola nan c'est glauque en soit, nan me la faite pas ! Aucun enfant
est ravi de voir ça vraiment, j'suis sûr en plus c'est vraiment un truc de ouf qui doit
coûter hyper cher, regardez c'est vraiment complet quoi. Regarde ça mec
j'ai pas envie d'l'entendre chanter ce truc. Les cassettes datent de
1985. Je ne sais pas comment le refaire marcher.
Le refais jamais marcher mec, y a au moins 800 démons qui vont venir posséder ta
maison. Sur Craigslist y a un truc que j'avais pas dis la dernière
fois c'est que des fois les gens utilisent Craigslist pour retrouver
quelqu'un ou faire passer un message à quelqu'un là par exemple c'est un mec qui est allé à l'hôpital
et qui adresse un message à quelqu'un qui l'a vu là bas. "C'était dans la nuit de
jeudi. J'avais une infection urinaire et tu étais comme Hermione d'Harry Potter.
Tu m'as comme jeté un sort avec ta baguette à ultrasons. J'étais
venue avec mon copain mais je le quitterais pour toi car tu sais comment faire marcher les choses.
Dis moi de quelle taille était le kist sur mon ovaire et je saurais
que c'est toi." *petit rire* C'est génial JADORE
Olaaa... Il vend un bateau de 9 mètres gratuit. " Grand-Père
était un marin. Il vivait loin de la mer et a donc loué une grue pour laisser
tomber un voilier dans sa piscine. *rire* Il est temps de sortir le bateau.
Gratuit pour toute personne qui arrive à enlever le bateau sans
endommager le mur ou se qu'il y a autour. " Son grand-père est génial le mec est
têtu c'est un vrai grand-père putain ! C'est incroyable, je trouve ça fabuleux. J'pense quand
je serais grand-père je ferais la même. Si j'veux une moto neige bah j'prends une moto neige
neige ou pas j'men bas les couilles. Oooooh un autre message que quelqu'un adresse à un autre
mais cette fois c'est, c'est mignon. C'est pas négatif.
" En 2009 j'ai adopté ce chien à une famille qui vivait à Saint-Charles.
Le 13 février 2009 je suis venu chez vous le chercher, j'ai promis à votre
fille que je lui donnerais tout l'amour que j'ai et que sa vie serait belle.
Aujourd'hui il fait entièrement partie de la famille.
On partage nos journées ensembles et même nos vacances. Récemment,
on a découvert qu'il avait des problèmes de cœur et de respiration
Aujourd'hui il a perdu sa bataille et on a du lui dire au revoir.
Je vous ai toujours été reconnaissant de nous avoir donné le chien le plus
aimant, mignon et sympathique qu'il n'ai jamais existé. "
* bruit *
C'est triste !!
Pourquoi j'ai mis cette annonce là !
En plus y a des photos, il est trop mignooonn... Pourquoi j'ai mis
ça. Putain on devait rire ça a tué l'ambiance là ! Oh !
"Une KIA OPTIMA de 2014 avec quelques dommages à l'arrière"
ça sent le guet-apens."La voiture marche nickel et roule
34 000 km au compteur. Transmission automatique, 4
cylindres. Je demande 4 500 dollars
Nan mais mec, mais t'as pas honte, "quelques dommages à
l'arrière." Mon gars tema ton coffre vieux.
Nan mais mec c'est abu... Tu peux même pas rouler
regarde le pot d'échapement mec. Le "skate de la mort"
"Mon fils a construit ça pour lui est ses copains. Vous vous allongez
dessus et descendez les rues pavées. Lui et ses amis sont tous blessés maintenant."
*rire* Mec tema la planche quoi, elle fait rêver son-per
C'est horrible, ils ont des pu**n de roues de rollers et en bas des roues de
skate cross. "Un projet unique en son genre. Une voiture mi-Corvette
mi-avion"
"Un avion de 1963, une corvette de 84.
Inattendu. Unique en son genre."
Mec c'est cheum.
C'est un scandale mon gars. J'pense que dans son esprit
ça donnait un truc trop stylé trop beau et tout et quand il l'a fait il l'as regardé
et il l'a mis sur Craigslist. "Un danseur Thaïlandais de la masculinité
OK arrêtez tout et réfléchissez "Reposez-vous et observez le
danseur thaïlandais de la masculinité. Regardez dans ses yeux
il est celui que vous attendiez il vous restaurera, il vous guérira.
Il regardera dans votre âme et apaisera cette douleur.
Vois comme il te sourit.
Il m'a soigné je dois maintenant le passer a quelqu’un d'autre
comme il me l'a demandé. "Alors je n'ai aucune
idée de ce que
c'est que cette sculpture c'est peut-être un truc hyper
connu là-bas, ou pas... Mais cela dis
Je pense très fortement que cet objet est
possédé. mec tu m'dis d'embrasser Anabelle ou ce danseur j'embrasse Anabelle
Le mec il est génial j'adore ! Il veut vendre
sa pu**n de voiture. OK c'est une Jeep, personne ferait
la gueule en voyant cette voiture, elle est très cool. Mais pour lui ce n'est pas assez, lui
il veut la vendre. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on veux vendre une voiture à tout prix ?
On fait des photos montage et on la fout dans Mad Max mon gars
eh oui ! Regardez ça comme c'est bien incrusté. c'est tellement
drôle
ça me fait rire
ce mec est incroyable je veux acheter sa voiture juste pour sa sympathie
"J'écris ceci au cas où tu aimerais faire partie de la vie de notre enfant
bientôt né. Je suis mexicaine Américaine. Je faisais
1m70 pour 65kg quand on a fait l'amour.
J'ai essayé de te dessiner. Je ne sais pas faire de portrait robot comme la
police mais je pense que la ressemblance est là."
Tema le dessin mon gars !
Même si il voulait revenir, maintenant il veut plus revenir.
Il a vu le peu d'estime qu'elle a pour lui, il s'est dit STOP ! Qui n'a jamais
rêver d'un costume de coupe ongle mec, moi il m'en faut un de cette taille
pour couper mes ongles de pieds, j'vous est dégoûté en une phrase
En plus ça se porte d'une manière nulle à chier. c'est le meilleur costume pu**n
j'ai trouvé, la pire
photo pour représenter une annonce. VRAIMENT ! Cet homme vend une PIWI 80
Regardez attentivement cette photo : il tient
la PIWI 80 dans sa baignoire et son chat est en plein
milieu de la photo, de plus cet homme est nu.
"Vend fort fait maison. Ma copine m'a dit qu'elle voulais me parler à propos de mon
comportement de gamin. Mais elle ne connaissait pas le mot de passe pour pouvoir rentrer dans le fort.
Le fort inclut un WIFI et une belle vue sur la télé pour regarder
Netflix. Protéger pas un gros chien méchant.
sauf si vous avez de la pizza. "Ah y a une photo du chien !
OUIIIII "Vend fauteuil à moitié mangé. Mon chien a mangé une
partie de mon fauteuil et il a pas du tout l'air désolé."
Je veux pas mettre la merde entre vous mais mec j'avoue il a l'air de s'en battre les cou***es bien.
Vous savez que ça c'est ma hantise avec Natsu j'ai trop peur que ça arrive.
"Vend scie circulaire, marche parfaitement.
Point fort : peut importe ce qu'elle coupe elle ne s'arrête jamais
Point faible : la protection fonctionne mal de manière
aléatoire. C'est probablement facile à réparer."
Mec t'as perdu deux doigts, tu ne peux pas dire ça.
Ne la vend pas elle t'a pris deux doigts déjà !
"Besoin de couches de poulets ? avez vous chez vous des poulets ou des
canards ? "Bah non non" Avez vous besoin de les équiper de couches
pour garder votre maison
propre ? "Bah non non toujours pas parce que j'ai pas de..." Nous faisons des couches customisées
pour poules et canards. Disponible en différents coloris."
"Vend gnome restauré
(peut être hanté) Je l'ai reçu de ma grand-mère et il était dans un piètre état.
Toutes les plantes semblent mourir autour de lui. Met les enfants très mal à l'aise.
A une petite chance d'être possédé."
Il est creepy as fuck mon gars, mais tema sa
gu**le, il a un œil de verre ! Il a un œil aveugle ! Alors que c'est une figurine. "Vend chaise de la mort. "
Bah en quoi c'est une chaise de la mort ?
Nan mais sans déconner, imagine un mec s'assoie
dessus parce qu'il est bourré, il a pas fais exprès. Nan mais sans... Ils ont mis des lames de rasoirs au
milieu mec. "Une table basse unique (qui blessera vos enfants)"
Mais mec, pourquoi on ferait pas une table avec deux fois
plus d'angles qu'une table normal. Pour que ton gosse est deux fois plus de
chance de se péter le crâne DESSUS !" Un porte chaussures customisé."
En vrai c'est trop pas c** ce qu'il a fait. Tu coinces l'avant de la pompe dedans et c'est bon. C'est vraiment
pas con ! Oh nan c'est glauque c'est creepy ça.
"C'est avec beaucoup de tristesse que je dois donner mes poupées grandeur nature
et anatomiquement correcte que j'ai acheté il y a des années quand je me sentais
seul. Je suis maintenant marié et ma femme m'a dit qu'elles doivent partir.
Leurs prénoms sont Susie, Sakia et Tenchi. "
Mais pose pas avec elle EN****E ! Pardon.
Pourquoi il pose avec elle ? Ca n'a pas de sens mec ça fais rêver personne.
On arrive très bien a visualiser ce que t'as fais avec là !
"Parachute Gratuit.
Je vends un parachute 100% fonctionnel. Il ne s'est pas ouvert lors de mon dernier saut.
Après l'avoir ramasser sur le corps, on a vérifier
qu'il n y avait aucun problème pour les utilisations futures."
C'est drôle. C'est une petite blague drôle. Sauf si quelqu'un est vraiment mort
parce qu'il ne s'est pas ouvert. "je vend un orgue Lead à 400 dollars"
Ca me fatigue. Tu penses qu'en voyant ta
b**e collée au dos du piano
t'as plus de chance de le vendre ! c'est ça ta stratégie ? Mec ! Les amis on finis la vidéo
sur un item trop stylé. Une pu**n de roue d'hamster à
taille humaine ! Pourquoi courir sur un tapis roulant
quand tu peux acheter une roue pu**n ! Les amis c'est la fin
de cette deuxième vidéo sur
les annonces Américaine. Je crois qu'on a torché Craigsliste y a pas une
annonce qui nous a échappé. Par contre rezoomer ça ça m'avais échappé.
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu ! J'vous fais pleins de gros bisous n'hésitez pas
à vendre vos objet sur Craigslist, personne les achètera.
Par contre des gens font des vidéos sur vos annonces
pour ce moquer de vous (je suis une merde)
En vrai on rigole mais c'est toujours une tanné
de vendre un truc sur un site comme LeBonCoin
et je trouve que quand tu rajoutes de l'humour même si ton
produit est pété, le mec qui cherche des objets sur le site il passe tellement un
meilleur moment. Oh c'est une morale de me***e ça c'est une morale de merde
et qu'est ce qu'on dis après une belle morale de merde comme ça ?
AU REVOIR !
*Outro*
Sous titres par T0mYT et Ian / Exo ! ~PEACE !~ (il nous manque...)